It's another edition of answer the internet delivered by Postmates I'm KFC host
of KFC radio at Barstool sports. For the last seven years,
our podcast has been dealing with the weirdest,
most difficult hypothetical questions the internet has to offer.
Now we're putting celebrities and comedians to the test asking them the same
questions. We got big Brown Brennan Shaw back here, once again,
his second appearance, the first time he came on,
it was the first episode of answer to the internet to really pop,
put us on the map. So he's back once again,
we're putting them to the test with harder and weirder questions this time,
anytime you need anything delivered anywhere, use Postmates, download the app,
use the promo code KFC for a hundred dollars off your delivery charge for the
next seven days.
What's up guys. I'm Brennan shop and I'm back. I am back.
Make sure you check out my special on Showtime. You'd be surprised.
Watch it for free.
Go to showtime.com promo code shop you get 30 days of free show time. Enjoy,
uh, come loudly every time you fart or fart loud. Every time he come, dude,
uh, here we go. Um,
uh, definitely fart loud every time he come. Yeah. Yeah. Just let it go.
You know what I'm saying? Like give him a heads up. I'm about to bust.
It's like a fog horn. It'd be sick about the bus.
Uh, you got offered a billion dollars to never leave the state of Ohio.
Do you take it? Nope, I'm doing all right. And I like to travel,
so I'm good. Nah, not that I don't not like Ohio,
but for billing. Nah.
Would you lose all your own memories or never be able to make your new ones?
Ooh, I have a kid. So it's different animal, different animal. Uh,
he's getting pretty awesome.
So I'd lose all my old memories of him when he's like one,
two and three years old. Yeah,
but now he's now the cool kicks in when he's a baby,
I'm just kind of like decide peace. Make sure he stays alive. Now. He's like,
you know, he's older. He knows who I am. Now's the time.
If you could have any two people fight in a no rules, cage match.
Who would you choose? Dad? I don't hate anybody. Um,
balls deep in game of Thrones.
So I'd like a real fight between the hound and the mountain.
That'd be pretty dope for like an official win, like a real like death match.
BCIT maybe seen him lately. He had a stroke.
Half his face is all up. The hound looks pretty gnarly.
How much money would it take for you to not know how to read?
Do we even need to read? I can barely read. I'm balling. So whatever,
what else we got for $10,000?
Would you carry around an animated body pillow that looks like a human for one
month. Have to introduce it as your boyfriend and girlfriend. Nope. Again,
fall back to balling going. We'll change that number. Uh, let's do a.
Let's do a hundred thousand. Nope, Nope. Half
a million, a million dollars for one
second. Carry a pillow for a month
with dad, his dad, a serial killer billion dollars.
You are in an open field, armed with a baseball bat.
How many ten-year-olds this is dark. How many? 10 year olds wearing it?
Could you take down before they get you?
Uh, man, uh.
I mean, how many are running at me? I would say a few hundred,
a few hundred getting can cost like a. You know what I'm saying?
Barry bonds and these little 10 years old, I'd be all right.
The first kid is just, and they're like,
Oh man. Yeah. And the rest of my, like,
I guess if you could have sex with any person you want at any time,
but you can only watch when
you watch women's sports forever. Would you do it?
God, MBA's getting good right now.
Sex with any person you want at any time I'm taking the sex sports overrated.
I'm watching the store. The WMB just balls deep in the Seattle storm.
Like get it, girl. Get it. This is a nail biter.
Would you rather go to jail for one year or go to jail with a Rubik's cube and
you can leave when it's done. I have a Rubik's cube seems pretty tough.
I seen children competed. We don't have a Rubik's cube in here. Right?
I'll do the Rubik's cube. Yes. I feel like I'd get it done.
Have you done it? Have you done it? No. Hell no. He has never done it one time.
I didn't stick the thing.
You don't think as grown men, you could figure out in a year.
I don't like the confidence in half.
I don't like your opinions on game of Thrones and I don't like your confidence
in Rubik cubes.
And now all of a sudden you're gonna stop.
Would you rather watch your dad have sex with the a hundred year old man? Wow.
Watch your mom kill someone. It's getting dark bros.
I know this is my second time, but let's take it easy, you know?
Um.
I guess watch my dad's sex.
No in man. You know.
I don't want someone to die. Uh, man, it's dark.
If you could pick one sliver to have your back in a bar fight,
who would you pick?
Uh.
Celebrity, uh, Frank Grillo. You know who that is?
He's in the purge stuff. He's tough. Frank grill is an actual legit, uh, boxer,
Frank Grillo or the rock. Right? And you think tough?
Yeah, those are too easy. Right? You're building your Dick from scratch.
You make it as big as you want, but for every inch you add,
you lose two years off your life. How big do you make it? Ah, dude,
I'm cool with, I got seventh. Fine.
Would you have sex with a girl with no arms? Yeah.
Flight for sure.
Like Cindy Crawford and a prime was like surfing and the shark was like,
like you're like, I'm still hooking up with Cindy Crawford. I don't give a.
If you could only watch one category of porn for the rest of your life,
what would it be? Big butts. I go for the big buts.
It's it's all sorts of race makes it's great in the
easy brassieres what's up.
Yeah.